oh
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur ce nouveau podcast dédié à la
conservation des espèces alors pour être
tout à fait honnête avec vous j'avais en
fait prévu de vous le faire en live sur
la chaîne twitch chaîne twitch que j'ai
déjà commencé à paramétrer d'ailleurs
mais qui malheureusement n'est pas
active pour le moment car il se trouve
que nous avons quelques soucis d'ordre
en ce moment et du coup les conférences
que julien avait prévu ainsi que les
live que je voulais vous faire sur la
conservation des espèces tout ça c'est
un peu passé à la trappe donc au lieu de
les remettre à plus tard nous avons
décidé de vous les donner comme vidéos
youtube tout simplement sur la forme de
podcasts ou de cours dans le cas de
julien en attendant voilà ça veut pas
dire qu'il n'y aura rien d'autre de
prévu après sur la chaîne plus juste
dire que pour l'instant le programme que
vous étiez censés avoir en live et vous
l'avez un podcast ce qui ma foi est pas
si mal quand même bien évidemment dès
que nous suscitons redit son règle et
vous en serez informés il ya facebook
twitter ou instagram ou directement sur
youtube on vous donnera tous les détails
à présent concernant le sujet du jour
nous allons parler aujourd'hui de
législation mais alors attention pas de
n'importe quelle législation de
nouvelles législations concernant la
conservation des espèces évidemment et
puis particulièrement le bien-être
animal alors aujourd'hui on s'intéresse
à une nouvelle loi qui est sortie au
royaume uni en juillet 2020 dunk de
cette année une nouvelle loi qui déclare
les animaux s'en tient alors attention
pas touche mais on va s'intéresser à ça
tout de suite donc voilà le texte de loi
en question
et avant qu'on commence sur ce texte de
loi juste une petite parenthèse
rapidement sur la législation française
et sur ce qui se passe dans le monde en
règle générale les animaux de compagnie
d'élevage
ou ceux qui se trouvent dans la nature
sont généralement considérés comme des
choses comme des meubles comme des
possessions donc c'est quelque chose que
vous pouvez posséder que vous avez plus
avez un animal de compagnie par exemple
vous possédez une vache ou un chat ou un
chien ou n'importe quoi et en
l'occurrence c'est considérer donc comme
un objet il ya bien quelques législation
de par le monde qui considèrent les
animaux un peu différemment on en
parlera tout à l'heure mais ce n'était
pas le cas du royaume uni et c'est donc
la première loi du royaume uni qui
contient le mot sans tiens en parlant
d'un animal et c'est pour ça que cette
les filiations est très importante pour
le royaume uni et je m'étonne un petit
peu qu'elle n'ait pas fait plus de bruit
parce que c'est quand même un grand pas
en avant vers un futur qui me paraît un
peu plus acceptable pour l'ensemble des
animaux de compagnie et des animaux
d'élevage ou autres animaux delà de la
planète en règle générale
on va voir ça tout de suite et on va
voir aussi les conséquences que cela
peut avoir alors peut-être pas tout de
suite mais si jamais on poursuit dans
cette fois il peut y avoir pas mal de
conséquences pour pour la société et la
manière dont nous considérons les
animaux au quotidien alors cette
nouvelle loi qu'est ce qu'il dit alors
c'est ça s'appelle les animaux warfare
7e acte toit ni toiture
c'est la création animaux sentjens
comique et donc à un comité sur
la sentience animal qui va vérifier que
toutes les lois qui sortent une nouvelle
loi qui passe donc par les chambres pour
être validés pour
pour entrer dans la vie publique au
royaume uni toutes ces lois respecte le
bien-être animal et donc son c'est ce
comité un peu garant voilà du bien-être
animal au point de vue législatif
alors ce texte il est un petit peu
curieux parce que ce comité finalement
on sait pas exactement comment ça va se
passer
quelle chambre envoie les trucs au
comité pas énormément de on ne sait pas
beaucoup plus sur le fonctionnement du
comité en lui même on sait pas combien
de membres à l'intérieur par exemple on
sait que les membres de comités ses
secrétaires d'état qui valait désigné
mais on ne sait pas sur quel critère
je suis pas trop du coût qui sera à
l'intérieur de ce comité avant il ya
normalement tout le processus est notée
dans la loi pour être bien sûr que l'on
fasse les choses correctement c'est vrai
que ça marche et là il n'y a pas grand
chose qui ait marqué là dedans qu'on a
un petit peu l'impression que cette loi
est uniquement là pour ajouter le nom
sentience le mot sentience dans la loi
du royaume uni parce que c'est un terme
qui n'y étaient pas voilà donc on a
juste l'impression que cette loi c'est
une sorte de prête noms pour ajouter le
mot sentience à l'intérieur et c'est
tout
et ça c'est un peu le cas d'ailleurs
quand on y pense parce que je ne sais
pas si je m'imagine que vous le savez il
ya le brick city ya pas longtemps le
royaume uni donc est sortie de l'union
européenne et il se trouve que l'union
européenne s'était déjà doté lors du
traité d'amsterdam de 97 il avait
rajouté donc une petite provision
supplémentaire dans la constitution qui
parlait donc 2
wolf et donc de bien être animal tout en
respectant la législation les
administrations et les rites religieux
ou les habitudes des différents pays
évidemment mais voilà mais il y avait
quand même ce terme animaux a fait dans
le texte de l'union européenne qui est
déjà quelque chose d'important et
surtout il y avait marqué qu'il désirait
assurer une protection et le respect
pour le bien-être animal en tant que
être senti en voilà et ça ça c'était
très important et du fait du de la
sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européenne à cause du bric cité par ce
terme animaux sans tian du moins est
ressenti en tant que quand on parle
d'animaux et ben n'était plus dans la
loi de coûts j'utilise était plus
couverts par le texte de l'union
européenne et donc il était important
pour eux de rajouter ce terme dans leurs
lois vu comment les mentalités ont
évolué depuis évidemment et c'est pour
ça que ce nouveau texte a été édictée
donc en 2022
pour en revenir aux textes de loi vous
noterez en dessous dans le petit
paragraphe 5 interprétation
animal dans ce texte veut dire tout
vertébrés autres qu'homo sapiens donc
que l'humain tout mollusques
céphalopodes et tout crustacés des
capotes donc les mollusques céphalopodes
les poulpes les pilotes comme ça et les
crustacés des capotes bas les crabes les
homards
alors pourquoi ces animaux là uniquement
et pourquoi pas les autres certes on
peut se demander pourquoi est-ce qu'un
crabe serait plus s'en tient qu'une
abeille ce que bon la bei quand même sa
vie en groupe il ya quand même une
certaine certaine cohésion une mx 2
groupes ils ont même un langage par
exemple alors que le crabe ouais vous
n'allez quand même pas si sûr donc on
peut se poser on est en droit de se
poser des questions c'est sûr mais il ya
une réponse toute simple à ça et dans
cette réponse il ya le mot souffrance
alors quel est le problème avec la
souffrance
on commence à s'inquiéter du bien-être
animal et de la sentience animal
lorsqu'on
[Musique]
lorsqu'on sait quoi utiliser ces animaux
soit pour les manger donc et une mise à
mort et puis après on va les utiliser
pour autre chose
soit lorsqu'on leur fait subir des
choses quand même assez désagréable
comme par exemple pour les homards pour
les crabes en effet bouillir vivant
du coup on est un peu en droit de
s'inquiéter et de savoir si
effectivement les mettre dans de l'eau
froide puis après augmenter petit à
petit la température pour que les pattes
se casse pas alors ce que lors de la
cuisson tout ça c'est la raison pour
laquelle on les met d'abord dans de
l'eau froide et qu'on fait ensuite
bouillir petit à petit lorsque le trabet
encore dans l'eau froide dans la
casserole et qu'on la mène ensuite à
ébullition ça évite que les pâtes les
appendices ne se détache du corps et
donc ça permet une meilleure
présentation dans l'assiette voilà vous
me direz de toute façon les faire
bouillir directement juste les plonger
directement dans l'eau bouillante ça
doit certainement pas être beaucoup
mieux donc en l'occurrence on est en
droit de s'interroger sur la sentience
de ces animaux est ce que ce qu'on leur
fait subir
est ce qu'on ne ferait pas subir à des
êtres sentiment tout à fait par hasard
que là ce serait quand même un petit peu
plus embêtant alors là vous allez me
dire oui mais depuis tout à l'heure tu
me parles de santé oms animal est d'être
champion sauf que je suis toujours pas
ce que ça veut dire d'accord donc en
tête commencer par ça une petite
définition de la sentience et pour
définir la sentience il va falloir
d'abord définir la conscience parce que
les deux sont liés à l'or la conscience
c'est quoi la conscience c'est la
capacité de nous rapporter
subjectivement nos propres états mentaux
donc en quelque sorte c'est cette
conscience de soi qu'on peut avoir cette
capacité de réflexion de créativité
cette sorte de sagesse si on veut cette
connaissance qu'on peut utiliser
ses expériences passées qu'on a
accumulées et c'est donc tout ça c'est
la conscience alors la conscience vous
avez l'impression que cette définition
est un peu décousu et c'est normal parce
que la conscience est extrêmement
difficile à définir et a certainement
autant de définitions de conscience
qu'il a de gens qui ont essayé de la
définir parce que la conscience et parce
qu'on essaie de définir ce concept de
conscience on essaie de le définir avec
notre propre conscience c'est à dire
qu'on est notre conscience pour définir
le concept de conscience vous voyez où
je veux en venir là c'est pas facile du
coup c'est on utilise l'outil en
question pour essayer de définir cet
outil dont comprenez cette définition
comme ce cas les uns c'est
juste une définition très basique de la
conscience y en a des centaines d'autres
certainement une dans le tas qui est un
peu mieux mais bon j'ai choisi de vous
donner celle qui est la plus basique la
plus facile à appréhender et puis de
toute façon c'est tout ce dont on a
besoin pour aujourd'hui on n'aura pas
besoin d'aller plus loin on va pas à
partir d'un des condamnés dans des
considérations philosophiques on va
rester assez basique mais une fois qu'on
a cette définition de la conscience par
contre on peut essayer de définir la
sentience parce que la sentir ce qu'est
ce que c'est en quelque sorte c'est là
une sorte de conscience mais une
conscience niveau beaucoup plus bas donc
ça va être la capacité de ressentir des
émotions la capacité d'avoir des
expériences vécues comme du plaisir de
la douleur de la peur mais ça va pas
être une certaine conscience de soi ça
va pas être une capacité de réflexion ou
de créativité par exemple on va rester
sur un niveau très basique de conscience
donc la sentience prenez le comme une
sorte de conscience mais de conscience
basique voilà alors attention il n'y a
pas qu'un seul niveau de 106 ans non
plus pour avoir des niveaux de sentiers
ans très basique et peut-être la
capacité uniquement de ressentir de
trois émotions
d'avoir quelques expériences n'est pas
forcément de pouvoir agir sur pouvoir
agir véritablement sur ses expériences
et d'en tirer des leçons en quelque
sorte et puis vous allez avoir des
niveaux de sentiers ans qui sont très
très proches de ce qu'on appelle la
conscience humaine qu'on va retrouver
notamment chez les grands singes qu'on
va retrouver chez les oiseaux vous
n'avez les perroquets vous avez les
corvidés vous avez tout ce genre
d'animaux qui sont capables d'avoir une
une sorte de sentier ans qui est très
proche de la nôtre
tellement proches que des fois on
pourrait s'y tromper et qu'on pourrait
peut-être appeler ça une conscience
d'ailleurs
voilà tout dépend de comment vous la
définissez
et c'est pour ça que 700 science c'est
quelque chose de capital quand on a
parlé de bien-être animal parce que la
sentience si c'est quelque chose c'est
un concept qui finalement nous fait
prendre conscience à nous en tant
qu'humain que les animaux sont peut-être
pas humains mais ils ont la capacité
d'exprimer des émotions de ressentir des
émotions et surtout la capacité de
ressentir la souffrance
et c'est là dessus qu'on va se baser
pour savoir si l'animal et s'en tient
aux noms cette capacité à ressentir la
souffrance c'est d'ailleurs cette grosse
question qu'on se pose c'est pour ça que
dans cette loi il ya tout et crustacés
des capotes c'est parce qu'on se dit que
possiblement si le crabe y laissant tian
quand vous le mettez dans l'eau
bouillante j'ai jamais été ébouillanté
moi même mais j'imagine que c'est pas
tip top donc
on est en droit de se poser la question
est ce qu'on n'est pas en train dé
bouillante est un être qui est capable
de ressentir de la douleur comme nous
qui est capable d'avoir des émotions
comme nous est ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de faire une sorte de meurtre a
signé voilà un an et c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que c'est important comme
question on est en droit de se poser la
question
et c'est pareil pour les mollusques
céphalopodes les poules les pieuvres
tous ces animaux qu'on sait
particulièrement intelligent d'ailleurs
il ya plein d'expérience qui ont été
faites sur le sujet
qui sont capables de résoudre des
problèmes des labyrinthes plein de trucs
plein de choses c'est assez incroyable
bas est ce que on n'est pas en train de
priver de leur liberté dans ce cas là
des animaux qui finalement une forme de
conscience et c est qu on ne devrait pas
soit les garder en captivité soit les
manger tout simplement parce que quand
on mange de la salade de poulpe bas
est-ce qu'on serait pas en train de
manger un animal se maintient c'est
peut-être là c'est une question c'est
une question qu'on peut se poser
et dans toute cette question de la
sentience est relié d'une certaine
manière à la douleur alors on a défini
chez des animaux on a essayé de
déterminer s'il était capable de
ressentir la douleur ou non donc il ya
plein d'expérience qui ont été faites
sur le sujet 1 il ya plein de modes
opératoires différents en fonction du
type de stimulus que vous utilisez mais
attention ces expériences là
sont évidemment fait dans les conditions
très éthique il n'est pas question de
couper une patte un animal et de
regarder s'il a mal hein c'est pas ça le
but quand vous essayez de savoir si un
animal ressent la douleur en fait ce que
vous faites mettons que vous voulez
savoir s'il réagit à des stimulus de
chaleur vous allez prendre une lumière
infrarouge vous allez lui lui miner la
pâte avec cette lumière infrarouge et
vous le laisser choisir l'ours qui
considérera que ça commence quand même
un peu à chauffer trop il va retirer sa
patte de lui-même dans ces cas là vous
n'allez pas lui le forcer à laisser sa
patte à l'endroit où la lumière si ça
commence à trop chauffer vous allez
calculer le temps qu'il met à retirer sa
patte qui va vous donner du coup la
sensibilité de cet animal à ce stimulus
précis donc en l'occurrence la chaleur
mais en réalité c'est pas la douleur que
vous testez dans ces cas là c'est autre
chose c'est juste la présence des
récepteurs sensoriels qui sont liées à
la captation de chaleur en l'occurrence
donc ces récepteurs sensoriels qui sont
liées à la douleur c'est ce qu'on
appelle les no 6 70 à l'anoci c'était un
peu partout sur votre corps c'est ce que
vous permet d'avoir le geste réflexe de
retirer votre main des plaques
chauffantes par exemple quand vous êtes
tout petit puis essayer de poser la main
dessus et que vous brûlez voilà ça
certain que ça brûle ça c'est les ponots
6 septembre qui envoie le message
jusqu'au thalamus dans le cerveau qui
lie attention ça crame tu es en train de
s'abîmer la pole à retiers retard 28
dont vous avez le geste réflexe de
retirer à la main et puis après
peut-être vous allez vous mettre à
pleurer si si ça faisait vraiment très
très mal parce que bon quand même c'est
une expérience un peu traumatisante pour
un enfant ne va pas se le cacher et
c'est justement là tout le problème de
la douleur c'est que on est tout à fait
capable de comprendre comment la douleur
fonctionne chez l'humain mais on n'est
pas capable de comprendre exactement si
ça fonctionne de la même manière chez
les animaux je vous explique
chez les mains la douleur en réalité
trois composantes évidemment la
composante physique les no 6 septembre
qui va vous donner tous les gestes
réflexes associé à la douleur donc
retiré la main si vous êtes sur les
plaques chauffantes par exemple ça c'est
le geste réflexe qui associé à la
douleur
mais il n'ya pas que ça il ya deux
autres composantes en réalité il ya une
composante affective et il ya une
composante cognitives à la douleur il y
a trois composantes au total donc la
composante sensorielle on l'a vu c'est
les no 6 septembre la composante
affective en fait c'est les émotions que
vous allez avoir vis-à-vis de cette
douleur est ce que ça va être pénible
est ce que vous allez avoir peur est ce
que
ça va être quelque chose qui fait quand
même vachement mal et que ça va être
douloureux pendant plusieurs jours et
que bon vous allez vous sentir mal à
cause de ça et puis vous avez toute la
composante cognitive derrière tous les
processus mentaux l'anticipation
l'interprétation de la douleur votre
adaptation du comportement etc tout ça
c'est ces trois composantes sont
essentielles à la douleur
et chez l'humain c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
fait que vous pouvez avoir de la douleur
semble en fait avoir de composante
essentielle certaines fois c'est par
exemple ce qui se passe lorsque vous
avez la douleur des membres fantômes
c'est à dire que met-on vous avez été
amputée
des fois il vous arrivera quand même de
ressentir de la douleur dans ce membre
même s'il n'est plus présent et donc
dans ces cas là c'est les deux autres
composantes qui vont jouer un rôle
derrière il vous aurait pu la composante
sensorielles ou alors exactement de la
même manière donc voilà c'est c'est un
peu le problème avec la douleur c'est
que vous avez trois composantes et que
chez les animaux nous ne sommes capables
de tester qu'une seule de ses
composantes qui est la composante
sensorielle et donc celle qui est la
présence ou l'absence de nos 6 septembre
c'est le seul truc qu'on est capable de
tester et non plus du coup tester la
sensibilité des no 6 septembre à un
stimulus donnait donc en l'occurrence à
chaleur comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure
mais vous n'allez pas pouvoir tester les
deux autres composantes à moins que ce
soit vraiment chez des animaux qu'ils
soient très proches de nous comme des
mammifères par exemple à la rigueur et
encore je ne suis pas sûr que vous
arrivez à tester ça chez une chaise une
souris mais chez un grand singe par
exemple vous allez pouvoir tester la
composante affective peut-être de la
douleur ou cognitif donc ça ça va être
ça va être des choses qui vont être
possible chez des espèces très proche de
nous j'ai des espèces un peu plus
éloignés ça va être plus compliqué vous
pourrez certainement tester la présence
de nos 6 septembre chez une limace mais
vous pourrez pas testé la composante
cognitive et la composante affective ça
va pas être possible et vous pouvez pas
savoir si ali massa des émotions
j'y arriverai pas vraiment à savoir si
elle a réfléchi à cette histoire de
douleur ou pas ça en l'état où on en est
actuellement des connaissances ça ne va
pas être possible
le bref aussi imparfaite que soit cette
méthode pour tester la sentience animal
le fait d'utiliser la douleur je dirais
que c'est un peu la seule carte
convenait parce que du coup les émotions
ça marche pareil que chez une certaine
tranche d'animaux parce que on pourrait
se dire la sentience c'est le fait
d'avoir des émotions mais c'est pareil
c'est pas tes stable chez beaucoup
d'animaux ça on n'arrivera pas à le
tester donc ça va pas être possible ou
alors on pourrait réussir peut-être
basse et la capacité à communiquer dans
ces cas là qui permet de savoir si
l'animal et s'en tient au peuple après
tout si communique c'est qu'il ya une
certaine conscience de ce qui se passe
autour de lui mais si on considère à la
communication comme moyen de déterminer
la sentience il va falloir prendre aussi
en compte les arbres les plantes parce
que les plantes sont capables de
communiquer entre elles via des
messagers chimiques par exemple pour
s'avertir de la proche d'insectes
ravageurs ou de danger que ce soit des
maladies autres trucs les arbres
certains arbres sont capables s'avertir
les uns les autres vient messagers
chimiques et c'est une forme de
communication comme une autre c'est une
forme de communication via messagers
chimiques après tout nous aussi on
communique chimiquement on a des
phéromones c'est une forme de
communication c'est pareil et c'est en
ça que
ça va pas être possible d'utiliser la
communication pour déterminer si
l'animal est conscient pas parce que
sinon ça veut dire qu'on doit vraiment
inclus à là dedans une grosse partie du
règne végétal avec aussi
enfin bref du coup tout dépend où vous
mettez la limite mais c'est pour ça
qu'on utilise ses expériences sur la
douleur parce que c'est plus ou moins la
seule chose qu'on ait de disponible
aujourd'hui pour déterminer
une sorte de sentiment chez l'animal
aussi imparfaite que cela soit voilà
c'est les seules expériences qu'on a
vraiment sous la main
alors ces expériences évidemment on les
a faites sur des vertébrés sur des
mammifères des rats par exemple c'est
l'animal de l'animal test par excellence
mais aussi sur des crabes et c'est
justement le sujet d'un article de 2013
cet article de 2013 a fait grand bruit
qui a été relayée par pas mal de
plateformes pas mal de l'association
animal aussi et cet article de 2013
avait déterminé que les crabes était
capable non seulement de ressentir la
douleur donc via les no 6 70 mais aussi
de déterminer si les crabes été capable
de choisir entre deux endroits un
endroit qui avait un stimulus pas très
agréable et un endroit avec un stimulus
beaucoup plus agréable beaucoup plus
normal
suite à leur expérience passée c'est à
dire que il les a émus donc dans deux
boîtes différentes il y avait des boîtes
où il ressent d un certain confort et il
y avait des boîtes ou au contraire tout
allait bien et donc les chercheurs
avaient déterminé que les crabes après
être passés plusieurs fois par toutes
les boîtes à les choisir de même la
boîte qui finalement avait été la plus
agréable pour eux de par leur expérience
donc ça signifiait que les crabes avait
une capacité d'une d'apprendre de leurs
expériences passées et ensuite d'agir
grâce à leur expérience passée et de
choisir grâce à cela donc il y avait non
seulement une capacité effectivement de
ressentir l'inconfort où la douleur via
les no 6 septembre mais y avait en plus
une capacité de réflexion derrière pour
avoir un choix éclairé ne sorte sur le
meilleur endroit dans lequel tu pouvais
évidemment c'est suite à ces articles
qu'on va trouver dans cette loi
notamment que un animal quand on parle
de sentiments son animal ça s'adresse
aussi aux crabes donc c'est à cause de
cet article là
par contre il va juste falloir rappeler
quand même et modérer ses propos un
petit peu par le fait que en 2016 les
mêmes auteurs ont publié une contre
étude qui finalement disait oui bon en
fait qu'on a publié en 2013 finalement
ça marche pas si bien que ça peut-être
que les crabes sont pas capables de
réfléchir sur leur expérience donc ils
sont effectivement capable de ressentir
la douleur mais après niveau
gain de connaissances grâce à leurs
expériences et réflexions à partir de
ses connaissances
ya par contre on voit là ce n'était pas
convaincant du tout leurs résultats
donc faut juste mitigé un petit peu ses
résultats
au niveau scientifique pour l'exemple
pour les crabes ça n'a pas été prouvé
qu'ils sont capables de réfléchir sur
sur ça
et puis comme je le disais au début
après tout si un crabe est capable de
réfléchir dans ces cas là on peut
supposer que des guêpes des abeilles des
insectes sociaux en règle générale c'est
aussi tout à fait capables d'avoir ce
même type de comportement ce même type
de réflexion et ce serait dommage dans
ces cas là de ne pas inclure les
insectes dans les lois qui parle des
animaux s'en tient si on inclut les
crabes j'aimerais aussi qu'on n'a plus
les hexapode
au niveau scientifique d'ailleurs on a
effectivement prouvé que chez les
insectes et chez d'autres petits animaux
il ya présence de nos six secteurs c'est
pas ils ressentent effectivement la
douleur physique donc comme nous ils ont
cette capacité sensorielle de ressentir
la douleur après on est incapable de
savoir s'il ya des émotions en plus
cette su comme chez nous mais au moins
physiquement parlant il ya les
récepteurs ya les no 6 septembre pour la
douleur
donc pas assez comme nous quand ils sont
malins ils le ressentent
alors ses expériences sur la douleur
chez les animaux c'est pas les seuls
trucs qu'on peut ramener nos
connaissances sur la sentience animal au
niveau scientifique et aussi d'autres
choses et en l'occurrence
il ya nos connaissances
neurologiques
sur l'humain et sur l'animal qu'on peut
aussi rajouter à ça
c'est à dire qu'en gros on a constaté
notamment chez les mammifères que ils
avaient les mêmes structures dans le
cerveau que nous et que du coup vu qu'il
y avait la même substrat il y avait
possiblement les mêmes émotions qui
pouvaient s'y développer oui si vous
avez une structure similaire ça veut
dire que vous pouvez possiblement
l'utiliser pour la même chose un peu là
dessus que basés tous les les
interprétations qu'elles sont basées
toutes les interprétations en
paléontologie d'ailleurs on considère
que une structure
similaire va avoir plus ou moins la même
utilité
comme ça qu'on peut interpréter des tas
de choses et en l'occurrence pour la
conscience c'est pareil on considère que
si vous avez un cerveau qui est plus ou
moins fait de la même manière bas vous
pouvez faire plus ou moins les mêmes
trucs voilà et donc vu qu'on a les zones
du cerveau similaire baham on se dit que
il possiblement les émotions qui
viennent de ces zones du cerveau qui
conserve nir de ces zones là sont
possiblement présente alors on en a pas
la preuve mais vu qu'on a la structure
on se dit que voilà il ya une forte
probabilité que ça existe et c'est
là-dessus qui est basée la déclaration
cambridge de 2012 qui dit que l'absence
de néocortex ne semble pas empêcher un
organisme d'éprouver des états affectifs
des données convergentes indique que les
animaux non humains possèdent des
substrats neuro anatomique neurochimique
et neurophysiologiques des étapes
conscient ainsi que la capacité de se
livrer à des comportements attentionnel
par conséquent la force des preuves nous
amène à conclure que les humains ne sont
pas seuls à posséder les substrats
neurologiques de la conscience des
animaux non humains notamment l'ensemble
des mammifères et des oiseaux ainsi que
de nombreuses autres espèces telles que
les pieuvres possède également ces
substrats neurologiques nous mais on
repart encore sur les vertébrés et sur
les céphalopodes en l'occurrence les
pieuvres la comédie
alors cette sas avait été publié en 2002
évidemment l'article de 2013 sur les
crabes était pas encore sorti donc c'est
pour ça qu'ils sont pas inclus là dedans
mais faut bien voir que bon après cet
article de 2013 beaucoup de gens ont
commencé à
intégrer les crustacés décapodes à
l'heure
leur quota d'animaux sentir en quelque
sorte les îles les on partirait en 2016
notre problème est là mais ça vient ça
vient de là donc ça le fait d'avoir les
mêmes structures c'est aussi une autre
pierre a amené à l'édifice de la
sentience animal donc non seulement ils
ressentent la douleur comme nommé ils
ont aussi les structures neurologique et
c'est donc suite à toutes ces
expériences déclarations de 2012 offre
avec toutes ses connaissances qu'on a
commencé à accumuler que
petit à petit la législation de par le
monde a commencé à changer ou du moins
inclure le mot sentiers en parlant
d'animaux dans leurs lois et ça se voit
pas mal avec la déclaration toulon de
2019 ou l'a carrément ce sont des
juristes de l'université de toulon qui
répondent cette fois ci à la déclaration
de cambridge de 2012 en disant que vu
que ces animaux sont considérés
conscient il va falloir leur accorder un
statut juridique cette fois là qu'il
soit adapté et donc dans cette
déclaration de toulon vous pouvez
trouver notamment nous déclarons que les
animaux doivent être considéré de
manière universelle comme des personnes
et non des choses donc c'est là où je
voulais en venir c'est que suite à
toutes ces découvertes sur la
nociception chez les animaux on commence
cette fois ci rentrait dans le domaine
juridique et donc on en arrive à ces
déclarations de 2019 à toulon alors là
pour l'instant c'est pas rentrer dans
les lois suisses une déclaration ça n'a
rien à voir avec la loi française pour
l'instant
mais en quelques sorte c'est un premier
pas peut-être pour un jour considéré ou
pour un jour changer le statut de
l'animal
vis-à-vis de la de la loi française et
qu'ils soient considérés comme autre
chose puisque dans cette déclaration
toulon du coup ils veulent considérer à
l'animal non plus comme une chose mais
comme une personne pour se dire qu'on on
va non plus le considérer comme un
meuble une possession on va le ramener
au rang de ce qu'ils appellent un sujet
de droit c'est à dire que c'est une
personne comme vous et moi qui va quoi
avoir des droits comme une personne
mon souci avec tout ça c'est que ont
pour l'instant cette histoire de santé
oms animal c'est très bien de déclarer
que les animaux sont sentis en
qu'effectivement faut les traiter avec
respect avec une certaine éthique faut
pas faire n'importe quoi que tu as beau
posséder un animal n'est pas censé lui
faire du mal voilà il ya pas mal de
choses qu'on peut essayer de développer
à partir de ça mais comment c'est à dire
que les animaux sont des personnes et
donc des sujets de droit aux yeux de la
loi ça veut dire quoi rêver ça veut dire
qu'ils font partie de notre société à
nous or pour vivre en société vous le
savez vous comme moi il y a chacun
chaque individu dans cette société a des
droits mais aussi des devoirs est ce
qu'il est possible de demander un animal
d'avoir à la fois des droits et des
devoirs
ça va être compliqué et ce que du coup
on peut leur accorder le même statut
juridique l humain je sais pas peut-être
qu'on pourrait trouver un statut entre
les deux est ce que ce serait peut-être
possible voilà il faut aussi comprendre
que si jamais on élève l'animal au rang
de personnes il ya beaucoup de choses
qui ont pu être possible dans notre
société
qui est par exemple la possession d'un
animal tout simplement vous avez un
animal de compagnie bah non non vous
n'avez pas d'animal de compagnie vous ne
possédez plus si c'est une personne vous
possédez pas la personne qui quand ça
s'appelle de l' esclavage c'est pas vous
c'est pas possible vous pouvez pas par
exemple
les élever pour ensuite les envoyer à
l'abattoir saad ça va pas être possible
c'est dans ce cas là c'est un meurtre si
vous tuez une autre personne et c'est ça
le problème c'est que du coup si vous
les élever au même rang que l'humain
dans la loi vous allez avoir toutes ses
conséquences qui vont en découler
est-ce que vous pouvez amener votre chat
chez le véto pour le stériliser 6 vous
considérez que c'est une personne bah
non
clairement ça va pas être possible on
peut pas lui faire faire une opération
comme ça contre son gré
voilà donc il ya beaucoup de choses
qu'il faut prendre en compte avant de
mettre ce genre de trucs dans les lois
notre société qu'on le veuille ou non
est basé sur des animaux alors que seuls
les animaux de compagnie que ce soit les
animaux qu'on utilise pour le travail il
ya encore pas mal d'endroits dans le
monde on utilise des chevaux ou des
boeufs pour pour faire les champs
que soient les animaux qu'on utilise
pour l'élevage pour ensuite les abattre
que ce soit les animaux qu'on va juste
un peu parasite est en quelque sorte
comme les abeilles
du coup les élèves on les protège mais
on récupère alors leur production
voilà il ya beaucoup de choses comme ça
qui si jamais on met que c'est des
personnes dans la loi ça va plus être
possible et c'est pour ça que du coup ce
pas n'a pas encore été franchie et si
jamais il est franchie un jour faudra le
faire avec beaucoup d'intelligence et
beaucoup de réflexion avant de faire ça
et peut-être faudra faudra attendre
d'avoir une solution de rechange avant
de vouloir faire quelque chose comme ça
parce que ça va ça va être très
compliqué sinon
c'est foncièrement impossible pour
l'instant de ne pas vivre avec les
animaux faut voir aussi que si jamais
vous commencez à considérer les animaux
comme des personnes vous n'aurez plus
non plus le droit d'aller polluer les
espaces naturels qui sont les lieux de
vie d'autres espèces d'animaux qui sont
du coup des personnes parce que vous
allez leur nuire dans ces cas là
donc toutes les exploitations tous les
choses où on va couper du bois où on va
extraire des minerais où on va empiéter
du coup sur leur territoire bas c'est
pareil ça va plus être possible on va
considérer ces animaux comme des
communautés
peut-être par email mais des communautés
animales pour locaux et dans ces
communautés animales et bah si jamais
vous commencez à endommager leurs lieux
de vie leurs habitations ce sera
certainement des activités qui seront à
la loi donc l'utilisation des ressources
naturelles sera beaucoup plus compliqué
dans ces cas là donc c'est pour ça que
voilà le
maître que les animaux sont sentir dans
une loi c'est très bien parce que ça
dénote d'une évolution des mentalités et
ça montre que effectivement on considère
plus juste l'animal comme une possession
que l'on considère que maintenant il est
quand même capable d'avoir des émotions
qui est capable de réagir de manière
d'avoir voilà d'avoir une sorte de sang
science et ça c'est bien de le
considérer maintenant il faut faire
attention aussi à ne pas aller trop loin
sinon ça à vitre être invivable pour
nous voilà donc il ya tout un panel de
conséquence à toutes ces actions à tout
c'est toutes ces lois ici vous pouvez
pas non plus posséder des animaux vous
pouvez pas non plus avoir de parc
zoologique par exemple parce que c'est
des endroits où on restreint la liberté
de ces animaux mais en cage en quelque
sorte même si c'est plus vraiment des
cages de nouveau il faut pas se leurrer
à part quelques parcs qui font qu'ils
sont restés dans le dix neuvième siècle
le reste a quand même pas mal évolué
surtout en europe où là on a vraiment
des parcs de zoologique où les animaux
sont soignés un régime cinq étoiles
vraiment mais du coup si on commence à
considérer les animaux comme des
personnes les mettre dans des parcs ça
vous donner un petit air d'exposition
universelle de 1900 avec les indigènes
qui ont ramené à paris pour pour les
montrer comme des animaux doha dans ces
cas là voilà tout ça c'est plein de
choses auxquelles il va falloir
réfléchir avant de continuer dans cette
voie là et j'espère qu'on trouvera le
moyen d'améliorer le bien-être animal la
manière dont les animaux sont traités en
captivité est dans la nature d'ailleurs
la manière dont on traite les
environnements autour de nous aussi
j'espère qu'on trouvera un moyen
d'améliorer tout ça sans pour autant
partir dans l'excès inverse j'aimerais
pour une fois on trouve un juste milieu
qu'on arrive à se mettre d'accord sur
quelque chose qui soit à la fois bon
pour les animaux est bon pour l'humain
alors avant de vous quitter
j'aimerais vous proposer une dernière
question pour une salle comme une espèce
de comme une sorte de petite réflexion à
prendre avec vous peut-être est-ce que
vous pensez que celle les animaux on
considère sans tian ont le droit à notre
respect et à être traités de manière
éthique
voilà une question très très ouverte ça
dépend encore une fois comment il est
terminée les termes respect éthique etc
mais je trouve la question intéressante
parce qu'après tout pour l'instant on
parle juste senti ans à nîmes a laissé
les seuls animaux qu'on inclut dans nos
lois ce qu'on considère comme sentir les
autres par contre ils n'ont pas voix au
chapitre
est ce que pour vous c'est normal est ce
que non est-ce que ba peut-être que
sinon on en fait trop ou pas assez voilà
donc posé moi vos réflexions ensuite
dans les commentaires c'est à vous deux
devoirs c'est un sujet qui est très
ouvert très discutée
très difficile à appréhender j'espère
que je vais amener la manière la plus
claire et la plus scientifique possible
donc c'est un sujet qui est très
controversé qui est en plein dans
l'actualité donc évidemment ça discute
beaucoup et tour mais je trouvais
justement que cette cette nouvelle loi
était l'occasion d'en parler un petit
peu de soulever ces questions et va
devoir avec vous ce que vous en pensez
thür a préféré le faire en live pour
avoir vos réactions directement mais on
se contentera des commentaires donc
n'hésitez pas et moi je vous dis à
bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures avec
des plumes
[Musique]